[Musique]
Gérald rosau je suis le responsable
d'exploitation ici à la Bergerie
Nationale de
[Musique]
Rambouillet le mineuse de Rambouillet
est une race historique qui est élevé à
rambouillé depuis le 18e siècle c'est le
roi Louis XV à l'époque qui a importé
cette race en provenance d'Espagne pour
ses qualités lainières et donc c'est une
race qui a été sélectionnée et élevée à
rambbouiller depuis 1786 pour être très
[Musique]
précis alors la spécificité du Minos
évidemment c'est la qualité de sa laine
tout d'abord sa finesse c'est une laine
très fine qui permet de pouvoir porter
les vêtements qui sont faits avec de la
laine de Minos à même la peau c'est une
laine qui ne va pas piquer parce que
contrairement à la plupart des autres
races qui ont une finesse alors qu'on
qu'on mesure en
micron qui va être de l'ordre de 30 à 40
microns pour les races générales en
France on va dire pour le Minos on va
être entre 18 et 20 microns donc
quasiment moitié au niveau de la finesse
et donc ça permetre d'avoir une laine de
très bonne qualité alors c'est des
animaux qui ont de la laine blanche
uniquement ils ont toujours été
sélectionnés sur la couleur de la laine
pour avoir uniquement des animaux à
laine blanche et enfin c'est aussi des
animaux qui ont une grande quantité de
laine c'estd qu'on voit sur les béliers
qui sont derrière moi qu'ils ont de la
laine du bout des pattes jusqu'au bout
du nez donc vraiment sur toute la
surface du corps ce qui permet qu'un
bélier Minos par exemple de rembouiller
va pouvoir produire entre 6 et 8 kg de
laine chaque
[Musique]
année la tonte se fait une fois par an
au printemps donc là cette année la
tonte des mérinos aura lieu à la fin du
mois d'avril et voilà ça permet de les
débarrasser de leur toison avant les
beaux jours et avant l'arrivée des des
périodes chaudes pour pour leur confort
tout simplement parce que c'est des
animaux qui sont pas capables de de muer
donc de perdre leur toison
[Musique]
eux-mêmes c'est une fierté parce que
c'est un patrimoine historique comme je
disais au début euh c'est une race qui a
été exportée dans le monde entier au 19e
siècle il y a eu ce qu'on a appelé la
minisation c'est la diffusion de de
béliers de la race mérineuse de
rambouillé dans en France tout d'abord
et ensuite dans le monde entier sur tous
les continents dans le but d'améliorer
les performances léniaires de des races
locales et donc aujourd'hui si on va en
Nouvelle-Zélande en Australie ou en
Amérique du Sud on retrouvera des
troupeaux issus du mineuse de
[Musique]
rambouille